Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
November 14th,
2016 what's going on?
I wow.
Yeah.
Uh,
my voice is a little messed up here because,
uh,
you know,
I've been traveling,
traveling,
traveling.
I've been taking my vitamins and cc over in Europe or a Gyno Dinniman's
tomatoes,
um,
Basel.
I don't understand why with ingredients,
you know,
everything else,
we pretty much pronounced,
pronounced the same as fucking Great Britain.
But when it comes to spices,
everything is different.
We say Reagan,
or we say Bazell they say,
or a Gyno,
Basel,
whatever the fuck they say,
tomato vitamins.
Um,
the only time I really experienced that in the United States,
as we say,
Carnegie in Pittsburgh says,
Carnegie Bill,
what are you talking about?
I don't fucking know.
I just got off a Goddamn plane and I,
uh,
watched all the football and the way out.
Oh my God.
Underrated flying on football fucking Sunday when it was too fucking games back
to back with seven fucking lead changes.
Um,
the boring NFL with their ratings down.
How great was Sunday.
Fucking amazing fucking amazing man.
Um,
that Dallas Pittsburgh game was incredible.
and the Pittsburgh Seattle game was great and uh,
I know a lot of people would think like the thing,
you know what the thing I was most upset about,
it wasn't the final score.
It wasn't the,
the lack of a call on the last play with Gronk.
It was the Tom Brady picture.
What the fuck was that with his hand on his hip and his other hand up underneath
this jar.
What in the fuck was that?
That's what happens when your data's supermodel.
She's in his God damn me.
Or just be like,
Tom,
you're just standing there like everybody else.
You need to establish your brand,
have fun with it.
Be a little Sassy.
Um,
yes,
you're probably not gonna hear this from a lot of patriots fans,
but I love the no call at the end of the fucking game.
I am forever sticking up for quarterbacks in the NFL when it comes to their
right to be there to try and prevent a score.
You know,
you know how this all started old gym or say out there in Indianapolis couldn't
beat the Patriots defense.
So he's the one that created the whole,
hey,
the cornerback can't even look at the receiver pass five fucking yards,
you know.
So I loved the no call.
I thought Gronk did that thing where he ran right into him.
He didn't quite push off,
but it was one of those gray area thinks you usually get a call on that.
I feel like 70% of the time I'll just throw that stand out there.
You know,
I don't read right.
Um,
I love the no call.
I wish that they would do that more.
Um,
but other than that,
it was just a great fucking game.
And I liked it too because Seattle,
it's kind of just played the game rather than doing all that peacock and around
every time they do something,
there was one guy,
that fat guy,
that nose tackle for Seattle.
I was fucking dying laughing on the plate that first drive the Patriots had,
where they just went right down the field and gave him the old right there.
Fred every fucking play was positive yardage except for one.
So we had like six,
seven plays in a row or just crushing it,
15 yards,
10 yards,
eight yards,
20 yards right down the field.
If you judge the game on that first fucking drive,
you'd be like,
oh my God,
this is going to be be a fucking landslide.
Right.
And then one plate,
I think they handed it off to Legler Garrett Blunt,
and he just runs in to the offensive line for no gain in that fat dude stands up
and he wags a finger like my tumble over at Bella check and the Patriots bench.
Hey,
all those other players are going to work,
but not that one.
Don't try that one.
It's the funniest shit out of it to me.
But,
um,
you know,
it was an amazing game and I actually liked the fact that we lost to them,
even though they didn't have Bennett.
You know,
they were kind of hurt and we still lost to him and it was in our house,
you know,
then I just see our house,
I'm sorry it was in our stadium.
Um,
it didn't bug me because if we meet them again in the playoffs,
I'd rather have last regular season game.
Um,
you know,
they,
we see that shit like,
you know,
you gotta you always learn more during a loss.
I liked way better losing,
you know,
I think the biggest thing that fucked the 2007 Patriots undefeated regular
season pages was the fact that we were undefeated also.
Spygate everyone was just rooting against us.
They would've loved it so much more if we went into the playoffs 14 and two or
15 and one just to,
you know,
so everybody would,
it didn't like,
it didn't have such a chip on their shoulder,
the fucking player.
Um,
I can't even,
why the fuck I just made that point?
Oh,
I know why because I've seen so many times.
Like it's like you beat them in the regular season and then they see your month
or two later and then they come back and beat you.
Jane's did that to us.
The jets did it to us.
We beat them first.
No,
they beat us first.
Then we destroy them at home and then a month later they'd beat us in the
playoffs.
And it's just kinda how it goes.
So,
uh,
am I right with that?
Um,
I'm still not too thrilled with our defense and uh,
can somebody,
by the way,
for the love of fucking guide,
and I don't want to hear this from a fan I needed from a football coach.
Can somebody explain to me the prevent defense?
I know I've asked this before,
but for the love of God,
can somebody please explain to me at the half the Patriot score a touchdown
we're playing with these guys were covering them.
They're not getting any
big plays.
We completely abandoned that.
This 59 seconds to go in the half,
we completely fucking abandoned that.
We start playing a zone defense or maybe we playing zone.
Up until then,
I don't know.
Whatever the fuck we were doing was working.
We were in a zone defense,
giving them a 20 yard cushion.
Basically you can see a field goal.
Okay?
And we just,
in 59 seconds,
these fucking guys,
seven plays,
seven 75 yards in 59 fucking seconds
and the last plate for the touchdown watching that wide receiver going from one
zone to the defense to another.
You know what he looked like?
You haven't seen when a fan just runs out on the field and he's just running by
players and they're just looking at them.
You know what I mean?
Cause it's cell.
That's a fan security.
We'll handle that.
This fucking guy because of the prevent defense was standing by himself like a
yard out from the end zone if not on the end zone line waving his fucking arms.
I mean he might as well have been dressed in street clothes.
The level of like nine coverages that is,
and I understand the concept behind the prevent defense is basically we'll give,
we'll give up the middle of the field will protect the sideline and they'll make
completions.
We'll tackle them and then they're going to somehow eat up this 59 fucking
seconds.
It never happens.
I swear to God,
I think it's a conspiracy.
It's a business move by the NFL.
It's to increase scoring slash add to the drama.
If another team is only up by one fucking score and the other team goes into a
prevent,
the game is going to end with three or four shots at the end zone,
or they're going to kick a field goal to try and win it.
It just,
it,
it just doesn't fucking work.
And you know what's funny?
So we go into the fucking prevent and they go right down the field.
Give us the old right there,
Fred.
Score a fucking touchdown.
All right,
very deflating.
No Pun intended for the patriots as we go into the locker room.
All right,
now we've got to kick off to Seattle.
We kick off to Seattle.
We played defense.
They go three and out.
It's like,
why the fuck didn't we do that before the half?
Sorry.
Half of this is emotionally half as I smoked two cigars two nights in a row,
which I can't fucking do.
I don't understand that on any fucking level.
I also don't understand
when the end of the game,
Seattle's scores a touchdown.
They go up by seven points,
why wouldn't you just kick an extra point,
go up by eight,
you're acting like a two point conversion is a done deal,
which is isn't,
which we saw when Seattle went to go for it and didn't get it right.
Am I nuts?
Cause I kind of looked
away from the screen.
Um,
they went for two there,
right.
And they didn't get it and then they were only up by one.
Maybe I'm,
maybe I'm wrong here.
I might be wrong if that's what happened.
Could somebody explain that move that they went to go up by two,
so they'd be up by a touchdown in a field goal rather than just go on,
let's go with the fucking 90 something percent thing and kick a fuck an extra
point.
Go up by eight and make the Patriots and they only have to score a touchdown but
then convert a fucking two point conversion
if that is in fact what happened.
Like I said,
I was on a plane and uh,
you know,
there is shit to fucking look around that.
Um,
and also kind of like,
what I like to do is I like to a,
I like to listen to like ACDC and shit like that when I'm on a plane.
So I listened to like the whole flick of the switch album while I was watching
the game.
It's actually pretty fucking cool.
Um,
and also you can actually just sort of watch the game and not getting nearly as
emotional,
you know,
because when your team is losing,
you start thinking that the announcers are against your team and vice versa and
all that type of shit.
So I,
um,
I dunno,
but I thoroughly enjoyed that game.
I'm not one of those fucking fans that fucking his team loses and then thinks,
oh,
we got fucked and blah,
blah,
Blah and all that bullshit.
Okay.
I don't,
uh,
I don't think that it was a fucking great game and I know you guys didn't have
Bennet and,
uh,
you know,
and it was great to see two of the most fucking,
uh,
the two biggest cheaters facing off with one another,
one guy who gets all the press,
the other guy does it.
Do you know Seattle since like 2010?
Um,
I think they recently got passed by the Redskins.
They were the most,
they had the most,
um,
people busted for taking roids.
You'd never know that they're in Seattle,
man.
They made coffee.
Nobody gives a fuck.
You do that where there's a little bit of foliage and all of a sudden it's a
fucking national story for fucking year and a half,
cause you'll let her cuts.
Here is what?
The air out of a fucking ball.
It's hilarious.
It's amazing to me.
Anyways,
so let's plow ahead here.
A,
uh,
I also got to do one of my favorite charitable events,
um,
other than the Patrice O'Neal company benefit.
Um,
tickets are on sale.
They are on sale.
They will tweet out the link again today.
It's going to be at the New York City Theater,
I believe February 21st.
They think it's a Tuesday bell.
It be Kinda nice if he had the actual fucking information,
wouldn't it?
Clicking on the camera.
Camera coupling on the calendar.
All right,
going in.
It's,
yes.
February 24 is Bam.
Um,
I got to do the,
uh,
the comics come home event and,
this is a really special event for me because I got to do,
I did it 20 years ago.
It was the first time they did it and think it was at the Orpheum and I got to
meet Cam Neely.
Chris Neyland was there.
I got to meet Dennis leary and I mean,
I was literally three and a half years into my career.
And,
um,
it was such an unbelievable event to be a part of.
And I went out and thank God I had a good set.
And I remember Larry called me and left a message.
I was so bummed I wasn't home when he called me.
This is like 20 years ago.
So I didn't have a cell phone,
had an answer machine.
And I,
you know,
I,
I actually remember listening to the message like over and over again,
and he was like,
uh,
a bill.
It's a Dennis.
Uh,
I just wanna say thank you.
you really fucking funny and,
uh,
you fucking killed.
This is,
thank you for,
uh,
for doing it right.
I fuck up.
And he just hung up and I listened to it like fucking 20 times in a row was so
fucking cool.
And um,
and I was also in a panic like,
oh fuck,
I didn't pick up the phone when he called.
Was that my big break?
We would have talked to it.
It became friends.
He would open all the doors for me.
You know,
that those,
those over the top panic moments that you have when you're trying to make it in
this business that you think you every,
every little thing you think you blew it.
Um,
and you actually,
what you ended up realizing is this,
this is not one thing.
It's a series of things all just building this fucking snowball that rolls down
the hill before you finally get there.
Um,
so anyway,
so I got to do it.
And a,
it was Jay last and it was his first one.
He did great.
Wendy Liebman,
uh,
Lenny clock with his fucking lime green pants.
Uh,
probably gonna forget some people,
Wanda Sykes.
Nick Depaulo than me,
than Bobby Kelly.
And,
uh,
that was cool cause me and Bobby will close in and out and he's part of my stand
up graduation class.
And I remember when we both first got to do what we would,
we were in the Jay Larson spot,
the first guy out,
the new guy,
which is really hard because nobody knows who you are enough and you got to go
up.
And that was just the Orpheum.
And Larson went up at the fucking TD banknorth garden where the Bruins and
Celtics play and he fucking killed,
look,
totally relaxed.
And I remember watching him going like,
I wasn't that relaxed the first time I did it and was just in a,
in a theater.
And,
um,
you know,
it was cool.
I had some friends in there too though.
That was their first a comedy show they'd ever been to when,
let me,
let's just say they saw the gamut of everything that can possibly happen when
you go onstage.
Man,
it was a fucking a,
it was a fun night.
It was a fun fucking night.
And uh,
you know,
and then afterwards everybody hung out.
And,
uh,
and I had these cigars that I brought and I was going,
I was saying to the people and say,
hey man,
we was there any place we can smoke these.
And one of the guys connected with the Bruins is like,
okay,
this is a room,
we can go to Sweden.
I'm going to this like halfass locker room.
It wasn't a visitor locker room.
I don't know what the fuck it was.
And we went in there and we just let these things up and just told stories for
like fucking two hours.
The entire reason I love smoking cigars and we were in there so long,
by the time we got out,
like,
uh,
they had broken down the stage and everything and they were setting it up,
I think for a Bruins game.
I couldn't tell if it was gonna be Bruins,
Celtics,
so sort of midway and just watching the bull gang or whatever they could,
they're called.
Just setting it up was so fucking cool.
Our,
uh,
our little Uber fucking,
our little car service back to the hotel had left and we were like,
yeah,
fuck it.
We were staying at the liberty so we just fucking walked around the corner and
uh,
it was fucking hilarious just walking down the streets of Boston if fucking two
in the morning on a Saturday night and every these fucking people hammered
almost a fight,
hear people screaming and yelling and shit.
And it's just like,
I dunno.
It's like God,
I remember this shit fucking the energy of Boston.
It's just,
it's so fucking unique.
It's really just like a,
I,
it took me a long time to pick up on it cause I was just in it.
You know what I mean?
It's kind of like if you car stinks when they see the commercial where they say
you go nose blind,
you don't see it.
I kind of was like,
I dunno,
I couldn't see how fucking nuts Boston is.
But I've said it before.
Boston is like the sucker punch like capitol of the fucking world.
Like when you go into a Var,
you just add at past a certain hour is this anger that settles it in the bar and
you just feel it.
Somebody getting fucking,
something's going to happen.
Right.
You always hear that dog hair about ob,
a dod guide,
fucking sack it in a bar last night.
Um,
some kids soccer dummy,
he was wearing a fucking clattering kit.
I'm not saying it's all like that,
but there's just this,
that at two in the morning that vibe exist.
I mean,
what time walking back from the Wilbur theater,
I can't remember where the fuck I was standing.
I was walking with two rows.
I was like,
man,
I man,
I just want to walk,
you know,
just walked the city a little bit,
man.
I miss it.
And all the memories,
you know,
back in the day going to Emerson College and commuting and taking the train in
to go to fucking Bruins,
Celtics red sox games and shit.
And uh,
I was walking and like there was two of the angriest fucking kids I've ever seen
him and length.
It was like these homeless people laying over the subway greets and they will
fucking walking by.
And they were,
they were just screaming,
wake up,
get a fucking job.
Like re they were like so angry.
They were like 30 yards in front of me.
And I was continuing to slow down cause I was like,
if I'm even anywhere near this guy's orbit,
he's going to want to fight me.
He was like that level of angry.
And of course it's got his girlfriend who's trying to calm him down.
Oh my God,
stop it.
Just,
just go to the car.
What are you doing?
He's fucking screaming and he's all fucking angry.
She's trying to fucking hold him and he's pulling away and shit.
So of course eventually he fucking sits down and he's just mean muggin everybody
come and buy and you know,
I remember he yelled at me and Derosa I'm just like,
just keep walking.
Just keep walking.
I don't know what it is.
I don't know if it's in the water.
I don't know what that is.
But we felt that vibe and uh,
and it was funny.
So we were actually walking back was me,
Bobby and a couple of his buddies and I'm connected with the show,
right?
And we fucking walking back and uh,
we did that thing,
you know,
it said don't walk.
And we were kind of standing in the street a little bit.
And these kids come around the corner in this car,
the kid and the jam packed with kids.
You know,
like everybody fucking piled in this kids fuck it in the back seat.
He's got this awful fucking mustache.
It comes,
if you drive by,
he's like,
hey,
you're standing in this straight as he went by
and I could tell me Bobby hadn't lived there in a long time and I just looked at
Bobby and I was just like,
you know,
we were standing in the street and he's like,
yeah,
he was right
now back in the day,
that would have been,
fuck you,
you fucking mustachioed whatever.
And then they would have pulled over and the,
you want to go,
oh,
you were fucking go.
And everybody's taking their gold chains off.
That was the eighties,
the eighties when he had gold chains.
And right before the fight,
everybody is like taking that gold shade off it,
handed it to your girlfriend,
keep your ranks are,
take the chains off,
dude.
Um,
yeah,
so it was always great to be back there.
And,
uh,
I didn't get to,
I came up to us so quickly,
I didn't get a chance to go to some of the old food haunts,
but my mother made some beef stew before I left,
so that was great.
A hung around for like a day,
like an asshole.
I hung around til like six at night thinking I didn't look that up.
The Patriots game was a,
was an afternoon game,
but I got,
like I said,
I got to watch it on the,
uh,
on the um,
okay.
On the fucking,
uh,
on the plane,
on the airplane there.
Um,
so anyways.
All right,
let's get into,
let's read a little bit of advertising here.
Um,
I have not watched the fucking Formula One race yet.
I know Lewis Hamilton won and he's closing the gap.
So you,
people who have not watched fucking Formula One all year.
I think the last one's in Abu Dhabi or some shit or Dubai.
I don't know where the fuck it is.
All right.
But this one is going to determine the fucking window.
I think Nico,
all he's gotta do is just come in third place.
If he just does that,
he's going to win it.
And uh,
Louis obviously needs to win the fucking race,
but it's kind of cool that it's coming down to the last one.
Um,
anyways,
let me get to the fucking advertising.
I have to hug my pipe,
my password,
or else I won't be able to talk and fucking,
there we go.
All right,
here we go.
All right.
Oh,
on it everybody.
Joe Rogan's company a on it has a new product.
It's called emulsified MCT oil.
Mct Oil is one of the fastest sources of clean fuel for the body and the brain.
It's one of the best ways to power up your performance or kickstart a weight
management program.
There are lots of MCT oil brands out there,
but there's none like emulsified MCT oil from audit available in three delicious
flavors,
coconut,
Vanilla,
and strawberry.
That's,
that's my DNA makeup.
Tell you this.
Every week.
Oh my coconut hit my vanilla scanning my strawberry pubes.
I'm also fight MCT oil like a mix.
It's like a cream easily in your morning coffee without the need for
a blender.
No mess,
no cleanup.
You can even mix it with your favorite into your favorite foods.
Right now,
if you go to [inaudible] dot com slash burr you can get on.
It's a most of the fide MCT oil for 12% off.
That's o n n I t.com/bill to get emulsified MCT oil for 12% off and for any
reason,
if you don't like it,
you can you,
they'll give you your money back,
no questions asked.
You've got nothing to lose.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash [inaudible] and get on it.
He can tell that's robins company.
He knows how short to make the copy.
Some of these fucking people,
they run a God damn lovel.
Oh,
here's another one.
give me an alum,
Lou.
Create everybody.
Be the end,
the envy of all your nerdy friends and get 100% off exclusive crates at Luke
[inaudible] dot com slash burr and enter my code burr to save $3 off on any new
subscription.
What is this?
This is a trunk full of Nerd Shit.
If you're into,
I'm just going to get to the point here.
If you're into movies,
if you're into action heroes or what a superheroes,
right?
If you like taking a bath with some fucking rubber duckies in there,
these people got you covered.
All right.
You know you want to be that debt nerd at the party,
that fucking,
it's got the fucking cool t shirt,
but that obscure movie,
these are the guys,
these are the guys that are going to get that nerd check to come walking up to
you right later on tonight.
You'll both take off each other's hooded sweatshirts,
um,
on a question or you are on a quest for epic gear,
housewares and collectibles.
Loot crate has it.
Loot crate offers an epic range of pop culture items for less than $20 a month.
Um,
if you're more of a fantastic fanatical Fashionista,
then try out Lou,
where this is,
I didn't know what a copy in the world do.
I have no fucking idea what they're talking about.
Monthly wearables and accessories with cult classics and your favorite
franchises.
If you want to get fancy,
get a bigger box with the even bigger lute with loot crate DX.
Get ready for number.
November's in chanting theme magical.
Oh,
what a wonderful world of magic here in November,
Luke crane has cast a powerful ancient spelled to deliver you November's crate
featuring be witching items from Dr. Strange,
fantastic beasts and where to find them.
I've never heard of any of that big trouble in little China.
I love that movie and so much more.
Kurt Russell there,
when he fucking had the lipstick on,
he was biting into that sandwich was fucking hilarious.
Uh,
do not wait.
You have until the 19th at 9:00 PM Pacific to subscribe for Novembers crate.
When it's over,
it's over.
No more crates.
Go to Lou craig.com/burr and enter my code burr to save $3 off on any new
subscription today.
Jesus Christ.
They're all nice and short this week.
This is fucking tremendous.
Can just plow right through them.
I think maybe the all got colt got together collectively.
It was just like,
we got to help this guy out.
He's got to have an aneurism trying to read out loud.
All right.
He has another one guys,
uh,
you know,
to go to dollar shave club for a fantastic shave.
Guys,
this is the way it just bring you all in.
Like we're all at a slumber party.
Uh,
when you probably don't know is that they have other amazing products to the
quality is the best on the market.
Their bodywash is great and won't dry out your skin.
They're pre and post shave stuff.
Keeps your skin soft and smooth.
There's stuff we'll have you looking and smelling like 1 million bucks.
Dollar Shave club's got stuff for your hair,
for your face,
for your underpants.
The old under carriage there.
Huh?
Don't forget the little bit up right for anywhere,
for everywhere to keep you feeling and looking fresh.
Once you're in the club,
you'll see that they've got the best grooming products out there.
They got a hot comb for your pubes and they're all affordable right now.
Right now's your chance to see for yourself why so many people love dollar shave
club.
If you're not a member yet,
and I've never joined,
now's the time.
You'll get your first month of razors for free.
Just pay shipping after that.
It's only a few bucks.
Join today.
Go to dollar shave club.com/bird that's dollar shave club.com/bar.
Um,
all right,
we got what?
We got?
Two more.
All right.
Fuck that.
I'll,
I'll read those later.
All right.
Okay.
Back to the podcast.
So anyways,
um,
yeah,
sweating,
get a chance to fucking race was in Brazil.
I got a tape at home.
I can't wait to see it cause it was raining.
And uh,
that's one of the coolest things I find about a formula one racing is that it's
like football.
They don't give a shit,
you know,
if it's raining or not,
they're going to keep,
they're going to keep racing.
And uh,
I think that's cool.
Then adds all this extra elements to the race.
And um,
you know,
it's like when two teams,
like my team's favored by 14 and all of a sudden it starts fucking rain and I
don't,
everybody starts to slip,
sliding around and you've got yourself a good game.
I thought that this was going to be a landslide one way or the other.
Like Hillary Clinton.
I still can't believe Donald Trump won.
I still cannot fucking believe that.
Um,
he reality show TV star gun fucking elected.
Oh Geez.
Um,
two of the worst fucking candidates ever to fucking face each others in my uncle
fucking opinion.
Boy.
What the fuck do I know?
Every dentally I know a lot considering a lot of the fucking emails I got and
all this shit on Twitter.
I got a lot of shit from my parents on a Conant,
which I gotta be honest with you guys,
was not a fucking easy one to do.
It was the day after the election.
Everyone was in shock,
I think including Trump supporters because I went back east and I talked to a
couple friends of mine and they voted for Trump.
And I was like,
dude,
I can't believe that guy wanted,
and they were like,
yeah,
I can't fucking believe it either.
So I don't know.
Maybe this is like when the Patriots beat the rams,
I have no fucking idea.
But anyways,
that was not an easy,
uh,
an easy spot to be in.
You know,
and I stayed true to who I was.
And uninformed jackass who can't fucking read out loud,
who's in the conspiracy theory.
I talked about Hillary dressing up like a Yak and fucking people under a
mountain.
I talked about Trump being a dope and that whole ridiculous shit about building
a fucking wall.
I trashed.
And both equally,
but you know,
people who vote for colors,
right?
You got a blue tie,
you can say nothing wrong.
You got a red tie.
You can't do anything wrong.
Right?
I got so much fucking shit.
It's so amazing how people Paul here things.
I actually,
my point in all of that was like,
you know,
it'd be kind of cool if we all just stop yelling at each other.
All right.
If you guys,
if,
if you want to hear my fucking theories,
this is my theory.
Okay.
I think Trump got in because of eight years of Obama and the progressive left.
And I think they got in because of eight years of George Bush and I think,
and Bush and Cheney.
And I think they got in because of eight years of Clinton.
And I think Clinton got in because of 12 years of Reagan and Bush.
It just,
it just keeps,
it goes like way conservative and then it goes way fucking liberal and then it
goes way conservative.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
think about where America was,
right?
Where when Bush and Cheney were there,
all right.
And then six years later or so during Obama's presidency,
like Bruce Jenner transitioned,
got her own show.
It was named woman of the year.
Okay.
Now that is not something that you would think could happen in oh seven six
years later bump.
That's where the Fuck Zach and I dunno.
And what I,
the,
my problem with both sides is the way they ran their ideology down your fucking
throat.
And that if you have a difference of an opinion,
you know,
on the right,
it's usually,
it means you're against America.
You don't support the troops and a,
you're a socialist.
And on the left,
if you don't agree with them,
you're a cave man.
You're a fucking sexist.
You're a racist,
you're a homophobia or any of those fucking things.
Um,
but both sides equally try to get you to lose your job and they try to destroy
your ability to earn a living because of your beliefs and full of life of me.
As confusing as the prevent defense is.
Can somebody please explain to me how if somebody says something politically or
socially that you don't agree with,
um,
spawning a movement to get them to lose their fucking job.
How that that person,
I'm more supportive of the troops.
America,
less of a socialist,
whatever the fuck it is you think they are or how that makes them less racist,
less time.
Biphobic like,
um,
I dunno,
I,
that doesn't work.
Yelling at people,
taking away their jobs.
You know what I mean?
It's like a way back when the Dixie chicks criticized George Bush the fucking
right.
All of a sudden that there they pressured radio stations to not play their
music.
They will,
they will fucking running over this cds with steam rollers and you know,
people like to,
what the fuck you going a little far?
It's like,
no,
they had a right to say that and we had a right to respond.
It's tit for tat.
It's like,
that's not tit for tat.
You know,
tit for tat is they trashed George Bush.
You defend
George Bush and you trashed them.
Trying to systematically destroy their career and their ability to make a living
is not tit for tat.
That's like somebody flipped your fucking ear and then you took out of a fucking
knife and cut.
They're trying to cut that juggler.
So,
and personally speaking,
I think both sides are,
uh,
are really guilty of that.
They're really guilty when you get really far left and you get really far left
right there.
Really guilty of just a bully people.
And there's so fucking wrapped up in that.
They're so God damn right about everything that they really become condescending
in sufferable assholes.
And um,
I dunno.
So I tried to,
I try to stay in the middle cause I would never tell you who the fuck to vote
for,
nor did I ever
on this thing unlike what most people saw.
Dude,
I got people on fucking Twitter.
It's hilarious.
Like they sit in there,
first of all,
they think they know me cause they watched me on a talk show and then they think
they know how I voted.
Like the amount of people that thought I voted for Trump.
And then the amount of people that thought I voted for Hillary,
all the Trump people think I voted for fucking Hillary and all the Trump,
all the Hillary people think I voted for Trump.
I didn't vote for either one of them.
I told you guys right along,
Bernie Sanders was my fucking guy.
That was my fucking guy.
And watching him getting boxed out by the media because they felt Hillary had
more of a chance and they didn't give a shit that they would just voting just
more of the same,
more of the same.
MMM.
The only thing I will commend with the right as they got their Bernie Sanders
in,
I mean,
the guy's a fucking shit show.
Yeah.
But at least,
you know,
at least they stuck by their rebel.
I wish that they had done that.
I would've loved to Saint Bernie against fucking Donald Trump.
I think Bernie would have had a better shot.
I just think the Clintons had too much fucking,
yeah.
Can
baggage,
you know,
and even as a Clinton supporter,
that's fucking true.
How little did Bill Clinton talk during that whole fucking time?
He didn't talk at all.
This is a former fucking president who had a successful presidency.
I mean,
even though he got impeached for stickiness and go lion about,
you know,
Monica Lewinsky,
he didn't talk like Al Gore lost to George Bush.
You know,
he didn't use Bill Clinton.
He goes,
I got to get the fuck away from you.
Dude,
you're a fucking nightmare.
You're a fucking nightmare.
You're a political fucking nightmare.
And the dude's on Wayfair had to do the exact same fucking thing.
I Dunno,
they had a ton of fucking baggage,
you know,
and Hillary supporters won't fucking look at it objectively at the same way
Trump supporters won't look at that.
I mean,
um,
I dunno.
It's just,
it's a fucked up time.
But I will tell you this though,
at the time for screaming and yelling at each other is over.
I feel,
and it would be nice is if those people who aren't crazy fucking left and crazy,
right,
could kind of maybe a break bread a little bit,
um,
which I don't think it's going to happen because,
of eight years of Obama in eight years of progressive,
the progressive left becoming word police and,
uh,
and,
um,
I get social police and an idea police and all of this stuff telling you what
the fuck you supposed to think about everything and what you're supposed to say
and what were you supposed to use.
And I really think it's overly simplifying,
saying that the right voted the way they did because they want to say homophobic
in racial slurs.
Just turning people into it.
That's his,
like both of them,
they always turn each other and do like a cartoon.
Like he ever even noticed.
Like whenever like a Democrat gets in the right,
totally overreacts and like it's going to be socialism.
It's going to be like cognitives Russia,
there's going to be terrorist running down the fucking street,
you know?
And then whenever anybody in the right [inaudible],
it's always like,
this is like Germany in 1935 every fucking time they say that every fucking
time.
I'm not saying that one of those times it won't be fucking true,
but they say it every fucking time and they completely freak the fuck out.
And um,
I dunno.
And then when they get in,
they ran their ideologies down the other person's throat.
They have zero empathy for somebody else.
They have zero empathy for how,
uh,
people want to raise their kids and they just,
both sides.
They just like,
we're 100% right and now you're going to fucking take this write down the throat
and a,
I dunno,
the,
each election,
I think the pendulum keeps swinging farther and farther,
but even if you're not fucking Democrat,
you get calf to be proud of the last eight fucking years.
I mean,
at least there was no cigars and pussies.
There was no,
uh,
they have weapons of mass destruction.
Oops,
we can't find any.
Oh,
now it's a liberation.
There was none of that shit.
Right?
Who knows who the fuck.
I don't know what's going to happen,
but uh,
you know,
I'm not comfortable with this result than anybody else.
But you wouldn't know that from all these fucking things.
These emails,
these,
I'll read you two.
I'll try and get through these next two emails that I got.
This is classic
like political shit.
How people like,
they just hear what they want to hear,
right?
So this guy writes me and this guy is basically I think a blaming me in a round
about way for Donald Trump getting in because God knows that's the kind of power
of the Monday morning podcast has,
you know,
a couple of hundred thousand downloads.
I mean that's it dude.
That's it.
I can't believe I don't have secret service security right outside my door as I
do this.
I'm literally a podcast where I talk about fucking sports.
90% of the time I talk about conspiracy theory.
I say I'm an idiot.
I can't read out loud.
You know,
this guy for some reason is choosing to ignore all of this.
I'm going to say because the person he wanted it didn't get in.
So here we go.
Dear freckles,
I'm no rocket scientist.
All right.
Immediately going self deprecating.
Neither are you okay.
Agreed.
And I think it's assumed it's safe to assume the large majority of your
listeners aren't either.
Um,
unlike you.
I would never speak for them.
I don't know.
I don't know who they are.
Okay.
But you know,
if you want to assume that to continue on with your point,
I'll go along with it.
Most are like me,
average middle of this person has not done one fucking ounce of research for
this.
But this is,
this is,
this is how we build points.
This is how I build a point.
Most are like me,
average middle class folk who laugh like a laugh twice a week from our favorite
comedian.
See this,
this is laying the groundwork.
I feel an overhand right coming.
Um,
you have swayed my opinion on several things over the years.
Old Jesus,
most notably,
I went from a Patriot hater to someone who supports them in,
agrees they are unfairly scrutinized by the league and other teams.
Well,
isn't that amazing?
So I guess if I could sway you on the amount of air that should be in a
football,
I could sway you on who you're going to pick for the leader of the free world.
Yeah,
I guess that's the same.
You know,
I,
I I get totally see that point.
I don't think there's any sort of giant body of water that you're leaping over
there.
I don't know.
Okay,
here we go.
When I realized,
when I realized how much your opinions influenced me,
I realized how much they might influence others.
Okay,
here's,
here's the big failure here buddy.
Okay?
You didn't agree with me on the Patriots.
I brought you around.
You didn't agree with me with my,
my political opinion on Hillary Clinton.
You didn't change.
You know,
I think that I can bring your fucking opinion around about using those savy
saved.
Fuck you fuck cards and your everyday bullshit life.
But when I think it comes down to electing the leader of the free world,
I think you go a little bit beyond the Monday morning podcast
or the Thursday afternoon just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast where I scream,
I'm just checking in on you like a fucking idiot for half a minute.
All right,
so here we hear he goes with his Z.
He's laid.
See,
he came out.
I'm no rocket scientist.
Self deprecating.
Okay,
Danny.
He goes,
uh hey.
Now he just goes,
well,
I'm going to assume that this is what your listeners are without doing any sort
of research.
And then I'm going to go,
Oh,
you swayed me on this fucking basic bullshit horse shit.
That means actually literally nothing.
Therefore you could sway me on something that means you know,
Jesus Christ.
Dude,
you walked through the mall and there's somebody sitting there going,
hey buddy,
can I talk to you for a second?
This is a self fair.
Look at this.
You can spray some spritzer in and blah,
blah blah,
and all of a sudden you buy some little impulse buy thing then then with your
theory,
that guy could also get you to vote for who the fuck he wants you to vote for.
Anyways,
continuing on,
when I realized how much your opinion influenced me,
I realized how much they might influence others and how these influences might
have much larger inc implications than the NFL.
Call me crazy.
But it seems like you're going into paranoia now.
Um,
after your polls said that you're a person was going to win and now you're
sitting there with your jaw on the ground and now you're looking for a scapegoat
in the air.
I am a 48 year old bald,
pasty fucking redhead.
There's an easy target.
Let's go after him.
I love it buddy.
But still it fucking tar and feather me.
Here we go.
You have consistently and foolishly bass bashed Hillary so much more.
So much more than you have Trump.
Hilarious,
right?
So much more than Trump.
I have an entire chunk of material.
Uh,
Donald Trump and Trump was so fucking easy.
I felt guilty when I was on stage.
I did it when I was on Conan about building the fucking wall.
How ridiculous and idea that is,
how much money that was going to be.
I did all of that.
I always called them a dope.
I always called him a reality TV show.
Star didn't even remotely respect him as a businessman.
I said,
I didn't believe that he was a billionaire.
I don't think that he could get you six grand in cash if he gave him six or
seven weeks.
I thought he was completely leveraged out.
I made fun of his hair.
I made fun out.
We didn't say anything to anybody.
He never said anything.
It was the most fascinating thing I've ever seen.
He would go like,
fucking a,
I'm gonna do this.
I'm going to do,
and some would be like,
how are you going to do that?
And He'd be like,
Oh,
you'll see.
You'll see.
I was doing a bit in my echo and want to use that with my wife.
Just make all these outrageous claims about what a great husband I'm going to
be.
And then when she gives me shit I,
well,
what are you going to do to improve yourself?
I'll,
you'll say,
no,
you need to tell me,
well,
I'm not going to give away my strategies,
then you'll steal them.
I did all of that.
Right.
And then Hillary,
I said that she was part of the Bilderberg group.
I talked about the Hillary Foundation and how they fucking been living off of
that shit.
They threw a $3 million wedding for their daughter.
All of that type of Shit,
all over fucking felony charges and everything,
which of course,
all Hillary supporters are like,
those were unfounded.
They were not proven yet with fucking Donald Trump.
Six or seven people say that he sexually assaulted them,
which I fucking believe I believe that to that girl when she went get real,
which I also said on the podcast,
and I was like,
dude,
he definitely did that shit.
You didn't hear all any of this shit,
did you sir?
You know why?
Because,
because you got fucking blue tie stuck in your fucking ears.
All right,
let's go.
Continuing to blame me.
All right.
Um,
I evidently,
it's so much more.
I trashed Hillary,
uh,
the entire election.
You have unfairly focused hate on her and at the end of your tirade,
you tack on,
Oh,
and he's a cunt to,
uh,
you don't seem to realize the influence you have on people who listened to you
twice a week,
every week.
Sir.
You've done nothing to prove that I have influence.
This is,
this is all something that you built in your head when you are hyperventilating
that this fucking monster got into the office,
all right?
And Hillary's a month's to two.
Okay?
And that right there was my all when she's a cunt too.
I didn't like either one of these people.
And that was my message throughout all of this.
Okay?
And that's just my fucking opinion.
What's I'm allowed to have our night.
Alright?
You most likely,
you most likely influenced at least one voter to vote for Donald Trump.
And for that you should be fucking ashamed,
dude.
This is all fucking conspiracy theory
because you chose,
you got somebody to cast one vote for the person that I didn't vote for.
You should be fucking ashamed because I only see the faults of the guy with the
red tie and I don't see any faults with the person with the Blue Blouse.
All right,
you are a,
you are so stupid.
Here we go.
This is all great to get somebody,
somebody to listen to your opinion.
Usually what she should do.
You usually should end with the insult.
Say your point,
and then you tag on your fucking ass hole because then they'll at least hear
your point.
But if you start to see if you've front end load,
all right,
you are so stupid that in one sentence you go from saying how they never talk
about this issue or that issue.
Then conclude by saying,
but I haven't watched any of the debates are kept up on this at all.
You fucking idiot.
Yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
You don't think that Trump supporters didn't say the same thing they did buddy.
Cause I got,
I have the exact same fucking email from the other side.
All right.
Which with my theory that I'll now use that also has no research behind it.
I would say that you guys all sort of canceled each other out.
So whatever influence I had,
I influenced somebody the other way too.
So I am completely exonerated here.
And if you look at the popular vote,
it was almost right down the fucking middle.
So there you go.
So you,
he calls me a fucking idiot.
All right?
Uh,
they never talk about climate change is something you've said on Monday.
the day before the election,
you have no clue what you're talking about.
Well,
first of all,
I said they never do.
I didn't say that one or the other.
So that was an evenhanded one,
right?
She goes,
clunk.
Clinton has made it a major point and supports the Paris agreement.
Uh,
nothing I ever saw.
She made it a major point.
She's commented on it.
It goes to the Paris agreement.
Not that you even know what the fuck that is.
You freckled fuck.
Of course.
See this guy once again,
making assumptions.
I know what the Paris agreement is.
I've seen it on the daily show.
I saw when they all talked about it.
I saw when they went there and the right finally said,
and I actually talked about this on the podcast,
sir.
When the rate went there,
then they finally said,
okay.
After denying it,
they finally said,
global warming does exist,
but it's too late to do anything about it now.
All right.
I believe I compared that to when Pete rose finally admitted that he been on
baseball and said,
now can you let me in the hall of fame.
I distinctly remember saying that,
not that you remember that sir,
cause you got your blue bonnets stuffed in your fucking ear.
Right.
I also actually looked up weeks ago,
like when did people first start talking about climate change?
As I was driving down the street and I was listening and he was saying,
you know I would drove,
drove down the street that morning.
I heard that on NPR they see scientists say the Great Barrier Reef is now dead.
And then they went on to talk about the cubs,
which is course struck me is funny.
Then the whole rest of the report should have been about that or that swirl of
trash and the Pacific Ocean and all that shit,
which none of these guys really talk about.
They do a little bit of lip service,
that's about it.
But they're not going to fucking do anything about it.
And even if they tried to,
they can't because he's corporations own them.
Which is why I like the fucking
the lunatic guys.
I never vote for the fucking main people.
I don't know,
whatever,
what happened,
let's just plow ahead.
So anyways,
yeah,
I actually looked it up and the first time climate change was brought up,
somebody had like a theory,
it was before it was even happening,
was projecting that the population kept growing,
that it was,
the theory was that we would heat up the planet and he did that in the early 18
hundreds I couldn't believe it.
And then there was a few more things about,
I can't remember,
it was weeks ago,
but like in the late fifties was the first definitive papers saying since the
1950s scientists has been telling people that the pollutions and shit that we've
been putting in the air or whatever.
Like I'm not a scientist.
Okay,
I am just a regular guy,
but I read,
they have known about it or it had the attention called to it since the late
1950 [inaudible] okay.
So I'm not as,
I am a moron,
but I'm not as dumb
as you think I am,
sir.
And one of the reasons why I underplay myself is because I don't want to be
another fucking jerk off
who's just fucking,
you know,
getting in your fucking ear like some people in my business.
Okay.
So anyways,
he goes,
uh,
Trump has said repeatedly that climate change is a hoax that was created by the
Chinese.
He said,
he said it repeatedly.
Um,
I'm going to look up the Internet.
See how many times he repeatedly said that.
Um,
usually when people say repeatedly,
it means it's a quote that somebody said like seven years ago,
uh,
one time.
All right.
And yet you blindly,
ignorantly spew your unfounded bullshit.
Dude,
you just define this podcast.
Why are you acting like this is meet the press?
He goes,
I'm not a genius.
I always back to being humble again.
I'm not a genius as you call me a fucking idiot.
All right?
I'm not a political scientist now.
He's doing a humble pie.
He's got his hands up.
But I took just a few hours out of my life to research both of their positions
on crucial issues and get an understanding of them.
Oh yeah.
I never did that.
I didn't do that at all.
And I'm not the one speaking to thousands of people twice a week.
You should truly be horrified at the thought you had anything to do with this
fucking train wreck.
I love how you would your,
do you think that Hillary has any responsibility
for the campaign that she ran?
I mean from day one her campaign could not use an unbelievable asset,
which was former president Bill Clinton
because of all of the shit show that that guy was both professionally and in his
personal life.
Her husband,
it was a former president that was wildly popular.
She couldn't even use the guy because of all the fucking skeletons in his
fucking closet,
you know?
And together they both had skeletons.
You know,
it's a very polarizing candidate that should pick.
And I thought in key moments,
you know,
where she really couldn't come up with something clever to say she didn't have
it.
Look sir,
be honest with me.
What really gets you into office,
your policy or playing the saxophone on fucking Arsenio Hall
or not sticking your head out of a tank and looking like a fucking dope or
getting too excited and going.
I mean that's the kind of shit that brings people down more so than anything
else.
And that's not my fault.
If you want to fucking blame me for that,
but that is the truth.
So you can actually win an election.
Like he just saw that fucking dope Trump do without saying a fucking thing.
But,
but being good at trash and somebody fucking shirt,
which is basically how he got in promising a bunch of shit,
not saying what he was going to do and then go look at that guy down there.
He's fucking clueless.
And everybody just laughing.
Hillary didn't have any of that.
She had no fucking swagger.
She just do it.
I remember when she did that hot sauce moment on that fucking radio show and uh,
the host was going,
everybody that was African American and she goes,
what's your favorite?
You know,
once you go to thing,
what do you always carry around with you?
And she said hot sauce,
whichever evidently was true.
Okay.
But immediately looked like she was pandering and the guy said,
are you just trying to pander?
Sounds to me like you're just trying to pander to black people and rather than
just saying like,
Nah man,
I like it.
I've been blah blah blah blah.
She goes,
isn't working
well that right there,
why the fuck would you say that?
Why would you say it?
And when I saw her say that I immediately as soon as that she's,
she is pandering and then people will go in like,
oh actually it's true.
And then I looked it up and I go,
oh it is fucking true.
But still,
this is the thing,
if I was really in the fucking hot sauce and I was fucking running and I was on
an all black radio station,
I wouldn't have brought it up cause it would've looked like pandering.
And then if I did bring it up,
sorry about my voice,
I sound like,
well through puberty here.
Even if I did brought it up then I would have been honest about it.
But like,
no,
I know it sounds like I'm pandering,
but there are some crossover things.
I actually really enjoy it.
So
do you mean you got,
she has to take some sort of the responsibility that,
you know,
she couldn't beat this fucking nitwit.
Um,
all right.
Over 300 of the top economists,
I'm not saying that she's not an evil to
over 300 the top economists,
including eight Nobel laureates came together to see,
I didn't know if they said that right,
that a Trump presidency would mean turmoil in the American and as a result,
the world's economy,
over 350 of the best scientists in the world came together to say his presidency
would be a disaster for the entire planet because of his dangerous stance on
climate change.
Not to mention Russia literally threw a party in the parliament building as soon
as Trump was elected.
That actually,
I'm happy a lake when Russia in the United States are unfriendly fucking terms.
It would be nice that we're not going in a direction to fucking keep pointing
missiles at one another.
MMM.
And you know,
for as much as,
uh,
Al Gore Al Gore,
I loved his stance on climate change.
He wasn't able to get a fucking thing done.
He wasn't able to stop it.
He wanted to fucking,
uh,
get a few policies in there.
They just ignore it.
And these guys are only in there for 48 years.
They just wait him out.
I remember when Al Gore,
when they have a car that got a hundred miles to a gallon,
I was excited.
I was in my twenties.
I wanted to buy the car.
They just kept delaying it and delaying it,
delaying it,
and then they got out of office.
Al Didn't beat Bush and then they just scrapped it and it was fucking over.
And that's what they do because they don't give a shit.
They don't give a shit.
You honestly think Hillary Clinton would have stopped global warming if you
taught Alba's 350 scientists that are all experts.
You know what else they said?
They said it's too late.
It was too late by the 1980s it was [inaudible] or something on the 90s.
It's,
it's Ben too late.
It's fuck.
And it's almost like not even a fucking issue anymore.
Um,
I mean it is an issue,
but the only way to do it,
it was we would,
we would all have to fucking go back to live in like cavemen and on 90% of us
would have to die and just kind of sit there and not do jumping jacks to add to
the fucking heat and helped us think could heal itself.
Other than that,
I don't know.
What the fuck are you going to do?
Is everybody's running around just having to get a flat screen TV and every
fucking room.
You know,
I love how it's like the political candidates are responsible for it.
It's like we're just as responsible as anybody else,
aren't we?
I Dunno.
Jesus Christ.
This is like meet the press here.
Anyways,
so the next time you open that stupid fucking freckle crusted mouth,
this guy like more enlightened than me.
By the way,
remember your words have power.
You are an influential person whether you want to believe it or not.
I don't expect you to read this tirade on the podcast,
but I hope you read it and realize what a fool you've been.
Why?
Cause I don't agree with you because you have all of this.
Admittedly that is,
none of this was researched if he just did 45 minutes or research.
Oh,
earlier you told me a couple hours you could see that.
Yes.
Hillary made mistakes with the email and Ben [inaudible].
Yeah,
she made mistakes.
Okay.
But nothing she ever did was criminal.
Exactly.
All right.
Well,
Trump,
he made some mistakes with women,
but none of it was ever criminal or he would have been fucking in jail.
Right.
He would have been brought up on charges.
The charges would have stuck.
You can do the same thing.
You're going to completely and okay.
You don't bring up the fucking Hillary Foundation or any of that type of shit
either or any of the other fucking,
all that other,
whatever,
the fucking Whitewater,
all of that fucking crap.
You don't bring up any of that shit.
You don't bring up the fact that they're both worth hundreds of millions of
fucking dollars.
And that's not a red flag to you.
These down to Earth Democrats.
What were men of the people?
They're worth a couple hundred million dollars.
The president's seat ps 500 grand a year.
How do they do it and don't give me that horse shit about,
they give political speeches,
fucking political speeches that they give.
Okay,
can you at least agree with me on this or that is just,
that's just those people washing their bribe money.
Those are the people that put them in office and then they go back and they give
a speech and they give him 300
grand,
250 grand to fucking speak there for it and give me a fucking break.
All right.
All right,
so there,
that's his fucking thing.
So he thinks I'm a moron and I got Trump to be fucking elected.
Okay.
Now here's something,
the exact opposite a bill.
You really are uneducated on Trump bill.
You need to run away from the progressive's.
This person thinks I'm a progressive liberal.
Listen to the exact same podcast,
sir.
Move the fuck out of California or whatever liberal spot you're living in.
Now,
this is what I can tell you immediately is the last person who wrote this email
is not listening to this at all.
It's just,
it's already yelling at his fucking windshield about what a dope this guys,
he goes,
I just heard your podcast about the tearful Democrats.
He listened to my podcast and he said,
he thinks that I'm a progressive liberal and for instance,
you had no clue who is going to pay for the wall.
Dude,
I've said all along,
I have no clue.
I don't know shit about football.
I watch fucking Patriot Seattle.
I can't name half the fucking people.
All right,
here we go.
Uh,
you have no true.
This is the funniest thing I've ever,
one of the funny things I've read,
you have no clue who's gonna pay for the wall.
Trump had a hundred rallies where he,
he asked the audience,
who's going to pay for the wall and everyone would shout Mexico,
do you realize that all you were doing was just repeating what he said was going
to happen,
but he never said how we would get Mexico,
sir.
Just imagine you didn't like your next door neighbor.
Okay.
And you was sick of him cutting across your lawn or whatever the fuck he was
doing.
You know,
cutting across the corner,
your lawn in making the grass go flat and you were fucking sick of it.
And now let me ask you this.
Let's say you decided to build a wall and you decided that he was going to pay
for it.
How would you go about doing that?
Exactly?
Now let's move it up to a fucking country level.
So we're going to build this wall and we're going to,
how are we,
how is he going to make Mexico pay for it?
And if you tell me it's only a guest because as far as I watched,
he never said how
economic sanctions you're going to pressure them into fucking doing it.
Okay.
Anyways,
and here we go.
How is it that those mobs mobs,
great word Dude are more educated than you.
Who the fuck is saying that the benefit of the walls will be jobs?
Who are you listening to and who said Trump doesn't want health care?
He's been really left on healthcare saying people with no insurance should be
able to get treatment and care from way back when he was running in the
primaries seating.
Then this guy thinks Trump is left on this seat.
This is why.
This is why sir,
the first person that you think I had influenced.
It's like people just
hear the podcast.
You guys already have your fucking minds made up and then you listen to the
podcast.
Okay,
and you,
it's like watching a football game and you're listening to Chris Collins Worth.
I met him one time when I did inside the NFL.
Chris Collins worth goes,
everybody thinks I hate their fucking team and like the other team better and
this,
well,
that's what you guys are doing with this podcast.
All right?
You guys are listening to this shit.
You lean left or you lean right?
And when I trashed your guy,
you think I'm only trashing your,
your man or woman and I'm trashing it more than the other people.
And then if and when your person loses,
you then blame my podcast.
All right?
You guys went out and you voted for who the fuck you wanted to vote for and you
listen to the information that you wanted to listen to and you listen to
whatever the fuck you were receptive to that vibe in your life,
which is the exact reason why when I,
I was doing this bit on stage talking about Trump's support is going,
how can you support this guy?
He's got people openly yelling the n word
at his rallies.
There's video of that.
Doesn't that bother you?
And this is what they would say.
Well,
you know,
I'm not,
I'd said this on Conan.
There'll be like,
we know I'm not.
I'm,
no,
I'm not into that.
I'm not doing that.
But,
but Hillary and what it is,
is what tracks for people is what's going to affect their fucking life.
And unfortunately,
when it comes to fucking racism,
it doesn't track with white people because it's not a factor in their life.
White people are not victims of racism despite the fact they say that they are,
when they talk about like affirmative action,
that that's racist because they don't understand that the reason why affirmative
action came about was because racist white people would not hire people who are
not white.
So they literally had to come up with the law to force white people to give
other people a chance.
And then what people do is they just look at that moment.
They don't look at the history of it.
They just look right then and there.
So I dunno,
I think that,
look,
I understand that right now.
Believe me,
do I understand going to comedy shows and seeing the way the fucking crowd is
reacting,
that this is a very volatile fucking time.
Um,
this guy goes on to talk about how fucking,
uh,
people thought Republicans were being dramatic when they said no to world war
three vote Trump,
but the democratic national,
a DNC,
fuck,
I don't know what the fuck it stands for.
Force Russia to,
uh,
why is it a DNP Democratic National Party?
Uh,
make my life easier.
Force Russia did dump tons of money into hypersonic nuclear missiles.
They have these fucking hypersonic characters that can hold 16 nuclear warheads
that they can penetrate our missile shields,
uh,
Blahblahblahblahblah and all this type of shit.
A reputable scholars were saying that moving towards,
we're moving towards world war three.
If you elect Hillary now,
they're all changing their tune.
Thanks to president Trump,
former host of the apprentice.
Get on board with Trump.
You are annoying.
Should be on our side.
See,
he doesn't think I'm fucking on his side.
You don't think I'm on your side?
Both of you have scholars in scientists that say your point of view was right
because what you guys do is you go to [inaudible] dot com and you memorize a
bunch of horse shit.
And then when your person does it,
when you then fucking blame a podcast.
So there you go.
I don't know what to tell you guys.
I respect both of your opinions.
I don't agree on either one of them.
I usually don't say who I vote for because I think it's a private matter.
But I did not vote for either one of them.
I vote for,
I voted for somebody else.
Bernie wasn't on the ballot.
I voted for somebody else that I thought was the best candidate,
not who the fuck I thought was going to win.
And I think that's a major problem is that people don't want what's right.
They want to win,
you know,
so they will go with a candidate that is a warmonger or a fucking racist or a,
or a corrupt piece of shit.
And they don't give a fuck as long as they're wearing the right fucking color
tie.
All right.
And I want it done.
All right,
let's be some advertising everybody.
Um,
but I do have to say,
this is,
let's just say whatever Trump is going to do,
um,
all it's doing for me.
You know,
he appoints this guy and he's got this fucking past where he allegedly said
something about Jews,
you know,
wasn't proven or whatever,
but,
uh,
he's got this fucking background.
Like all that does to me,
it's just inspires me to become more of a fuck an understanding person and try
to listen to people.
And as long as you just take that,
like,
that attitude,
you know,
I,
I don't really don't think a president should,
um,
make up your mind on who you should be afraid of
in what we need to do and what these people are going to do to us.
So what they're not going to do to us.
Just cause they fucking said it.
I don't,
I don't listen to that.
What I like to do was I listened to what the President says and then I go to the
country and I go to their fucking thing and I try to find some English story
about what the fuck they're saying about us.
And then I tried to figure out what the middle is.
All right.
I don't know.
I don't give a shit.
What color?
Your fucking tires.
All right,
so white people,
if you're nervous,
okay.
Liberal whites,
if you're really a fucking good liberal white,
you'll become even more fucking understanding of people that aren't white and,
and,
and debt are going to,
you know,
hm.
Bear the brunt of what this guy might fucking do.
I think it's your responsibility to become even more understanding.
You know what I mean?
And stop making everything about yourself in your fucking world because the
mainstream is already about that.
All right?
They go,
I'm off my gaining,
checked out a ticket or don't you know it's up to fucking you.
All right,
but I don't want you,
I don't to hear you crying about frumpy.
Somebody taking your fucking,
I can't stand.
Listen to white people talking about other,
taking the country away from us.
It's like if he looked at a fucking census,
you idiot.
You know,
you're fine.
Okay.
Are the water parks they're made for you?
Don't give us a second look when you show up,
like what's,
what's his element doing here?
They're excited.
You're there.
And within two seconds to someone in a mascot outfit,
fucking hug in.
Yeah,
there you go.
All right.
You're going to be fine.
Driving your four wheeler on your property.
MVMT watches.
Everybody pronounced movement was founded on the belief that style shouldn't
break the bank.
The watchmaker's goal is to change the way consumers think about fashion by
offering high quality minimalist products at revolutionary prices.
With over 500,000 watches sold to customers in 160 plus countries around the
world,
MVMT watches has solidified itself as the world's fastest growing watch company.
Woman watches start at just $95 at a department store.
You're looking at a good four to 500 bucks moving watches figured out.
By selling online,
they're able to cut out the middleman and retail markup,
providing the best possible price.
Over 500,000 thousand watches sold in over 160 countries.
Uh,
get 15% off today with free shipping and free returns by going to movement
watches,
Dotcom.
Slash.
Burrow.
That's MVMT watches.com/bar uh,
this watch has a really clean design.
I always hate this part.
It's like you already sold.
Are you going to come back around again?
It's watch has a really clean design.
Seriously.
Um,
evidently had been of been getting compliments ever since they put it on.
And not only am I not wearing it,
I actually lost my other watch.
It's a nice fucking watch.
Okay.
I didn't wear it cause I have other watches,
you know,
because I'm in my forties and I can afford a nice watch.
So I bought that one.
Know if I was in my twenties,
they'd fucking by this one.
All right.
And got to Mvt MVMT watches.com/bro join the movement.
But I didn't buy an overly expensive one.
I do not understand buying a super expensive fucking watch.
I just don't get it.
All right.
I don't understand it.
They'll just end up telling the time,
right?
I mean,
this isn't going to gay.
Drove a Prius for nine years.
I should have a movement.
Watch.
All right.
stamps.com everybody,
some small businesses still think an expensive postage meter is the only way to
get postage without having to go to the post office,
but they're wrong.
There's stamps.com with stamps.com you can easily print postage for any letter
or package using just your computer and printer.
Uh,
no extra hardware to buy,
no long term contracts.
stamps.com can serve you at least 50% compared to a meter plus.
You can do more with stamps.com and you can with the meter like sent package
tracking information to re to receipts with one click.
The choice is clear,
it's downstairs.
Calm offers more features at a fraction of the cost.
I've been using stamp cards.com for years for my show.
It makes mailing and Stan and shipping really convenient right now.
Sign up for stamps.com and use my last name Birdie.
Get a four week trial plus $110 bonus offer including postage and a stay at
scale.
Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the top of the homepage and type in,
uh,
that's it.
All right,
cool.
All right.
Anyways,
that's sort of the podcast.
Here's another thing,
like,
um,
you know,
I traveled a lot,
so I get to talk to all of these fucking people out there and,
uh,
I know somebody that voted for Trump and it was like,
I think it's exciting.
I think it's exciting that he's going to be present.
Obviously he's a white dude.
He's excited,
right?
And this is the same guy.
He said Obama's a fucking idiot.
All right?
Which you're free to say that you think he's a fucking idiot,
but you can watch fucking Donald Trump.
I got to do it.
It just,
it just,
I don't know.
That's what I learned traveling this country is just people here.
What the fuck they want to hear?
Um,
alright.
Lingerie.
Let's,
let's get off politics.
I'll give you guys a breather here.
All right?
But,
uh,
please guys,
just stop fucking yelling at each other.
All right?
It's just stop blaming everybody and just fucking be human beings here.
All right.
Let's be honest with you.
Donald Trump or Hillary Clinton or not out for you or for me.
They're out there for themselves and that's why there weren't hundreds of
billions of dollars.
Make no mistake.
All right.
Fucking sharp and a radio station with your height size for Dwight just during
the campaign and where the fuck are you going to be the rest of the time you're
going to be the White House.
Spain up fucking land on aqua first.
All Right,
eight Billy nipple slip.
I recently started dating this girl and we've been messing around for a few
months now.
Congratulations.
She's pretty cool and a really sweet girl and sex is great with her and all
right,
Trifecta,
however,
she's been doing a lot of lingerie shopping and wants me to go with her one day
so we can show up for her lingerie together.
Uh,
personally I never got the point of lingerie nor am am I a big fan of it.
I'm really just like,
when they just show up with like your fucking old
basketball shorts on you,
one of those guys,
as long as there's a pussy underneath it,
I don't give a bug.
All right.
Personally,
I never got the book and it didn't see the point of buying something that was
meant for you to take off almost immediately after you put it on.
All right sir.
This is the thing about,
all right,
so you're a,
you're a year one of those.
No foreplay guys.
All right.
If you really want to take it to the next level too,
like you ever have,
you ever make a meal for somebody and you sat it down and you turn your back to
the stove to set the panel back down.
And when you look back,
they were already halfway done with it and you're like,
what the fuck did I do all that work for?
Um,
I would let her buy that.
It makes her feel sexy.
Right?
And then,
you know,
get Sarah even into the,
the mood a little bit more telling you do it.
Yeah.
You're striking me as somebody who never takes the downtown sex,
if you know what I mean.
It just fucking ripped the clothes off,
puts her on her back,
fucking rolls off
fan and it,
then it turns on the fucking TV.
All right?
Also,
I'm not that great at faking my,
when her or a girls have broke out this sexy lingerie and I'm unenthused by it.
You know what dude?
Uh,
you're an asshole.
You really are an asshole.
Um,
and that can be a good thing.
You can,
you're going to get what you want in life,
but you're going to miss out on a lot in life.
Um,
it's even give got me in a great,
got me in trouble a couple of times.
The girls I had been dating for the most part have been pretty sexy,
but when it comes to lingerie,
I just think it makes things awkward.
That is the most overused word on the planet.
It's the default emotion of these,
this entire fucking world.
Now,
I don't even know what the word means anymore.
It's been applied to everything.
Everything's awkward.
I don't know what that means.
Same goes for things like sexting,
roleplaying badge and Ted picks and anything else that's kind of puts you on the
spot for things involving sex.
Is it weird that that stuff does nothing for me?
No,
it isn't,
but it shouldn't make the other person feeling an asshole.
Uh,
should I try to do my best?
I,
you know what I preempt,
I shouldn't have called you an asshole this early cause now you're asking
questions.
Sorry.
I apologize.
I'm wrong.
All right.
I should,
should I try my best to continue pretending that my wiener isn't shriveling up
like a sock when you pull the strings up,
the strings out of it?
Oh,
the,
uh,
the loans are a huge fan of the podcast.
I haven't,
if you haven't yet,
please come out.
I'm not going to say where he's from just in case his fucking girlfriend
recognizes this.
Um,
you know,
dude,
you could just kinda go along with that a little bit and like,
look,
I think like just saying,
you're not into sexting and in,
in,
in role playing and shit,
that's like next level shit.
If you're not into that,
that's fine.
Okay.
Um,
the larger ray,
I think as a simple thing you could put a happy face on.
I mean,
as much as guys think the luxuries for them,
and for the most part,
the way women dress,
like guys,
I look at it and she was hired.
She wants to dress it for themselves.
They like to look pretty.
All right.
That makes them feel good.
So I think the lake near,
can you come in for a second?
She's given me a look here.
Come here.
Oh Jesus.
She literally walked by,
stopped and look at me.
All right.
So this guy,
this guy is a,
Oh my God,
it's 10 36.
I've got to get off my fucking day.
So this guy,
could you look less enthused?
Yeah,
you shot me a look.
I thought that meant you wanted to come in,
but go on.
What do you Henry Hill.
I'm just listening
anyway.
Anyway,
to say.
Then they wave two towns.
Me.
All right,
so this guy,
he's got this great girl.
She's fucking cool.
She's sexy.
Sax Is Great,
but she's into wearing sexy lingerie.
It does nothing for him.
She wants to fucking him to go along on
it and like he thinks it's just stupid,
so she puts it on and she fucking pulls the strings like biodata.
Bu when he said,
I'm supposed to sit there and act like my direct deck is not shriveling up like
a sock.
What should I do?
He don't think,
he doesn't think lingerie a sexy.
He's just done it.
He goes,
I don't understand the point of just buying that.
None of it's going to take it off like two seconds later.
Okay.
It makes her feel good.
Just go along with it.
It's not going to kill you.
That's my advice.
Yeah,
it's fine.
It's just,
just go along with it.
It's now he said,
what about like sexting Vage and titty pics?
He goes,
I'm not into any of that or role playing.
You are so boring.
Whoever wrote this in,
I use really just,
it's like a job fucking prude and you're so boring.
Like loosen up a little bit.
Send a dick pic to your girlfriend.
No,
that's a bad idea.
Yeah.
I mean you probably should.
You never see.
You don't,
you never send any of that shit because it exists forever.
Yeah.
He'd be the one person,
it would come back to haunt him somehow.
So maybe don't do that,
but just open your mind a little bit.
It sounds like you're on a little sexual box and maybe you need to,
no pun intended,
you need to break out of this box.
But yeah,
here's the thing.
Explore something different and you know,
here's the thing on the Dick Pic,
Nia.
Okay.
People think,
okay,
I'm going to send a dick pic to you from my phone to your phone.
Just think of the journey that think takes my dick goes to outer space.
Yup.
Goes off a satellite,
it comes back down.
God knows how much shit is between that and that.
I mean,
how many miles that think just travel.
And to think that that's just going to go there.
And then if you're on like Twitter or do they say like,
can we want permission to have access to your photos?
And I never say yes.
It's like you can have access to this photo
know.
Yeah.
All of a sudden somebody,
you know,
you have to see your avatars,
your dick pic to somebody else's Avatar should tech pick?
Yeah.
Deck peg,
delete the deck,
peck and then NASA person to delete the deck.
Peck to no,
you'd never sent pics.
I gets down San bins.
What you do is say,
where are you?
I'll show it to you.
Like in the old days.
In color.
Yeah.
Like the old satellite Dick Pics.
Um,
but yeah,
in terms of this guy,
I think he should just kind of opened his mind a little bit.
Like I said,
it seems a little low prudish and it's fine.
You don't have to like lingerie and all that,
but I mean if your girls into it and you like her and she likes lingerie,
like hey,
what's the problem?
You know,
just like I said,
it's not right.
I don't see any problem with how do you not like lingerie?
I Dunno.
That's what I'm saying is boring as fuck.
You're saying he wants you to show up wearing his basketball shorts.
He just like,
just be naked.
That's what I was saying.
You know,
it was comparing it to like,
you know when you cook somebody a meal,
then they eat it in two seconds.
She just like,
dude,
what the fuck?
Like you do?
Huh?
But not in the bedroom.
Oh,
I do wolf down food.
You do?
Huh?
But that's not the only thing.
Jesus Christ Chase is Christ Nia.
Why would you say that?
No,
that's disgusting.
You take your time,
a woman in your,
in your condition.
My condition,
condition.
Speaking this way.
That's terrible.
What if other people were to hear it?
I know.
Let me think.
What would they think?
All right,
that's the podcast here.
That's it.
Oh,
oh no.
Well you got me here now.
Well I got to go edit my special.
I got to see how my,
especially at [inaudible] where I trashed both Hillary and Trump and still get
shit for it.
Yeah,
no and then Trump can't win.
Now you can't win.
And that's why I never,
I don't tell people who to vote for and I,
but I mean it,
it is like,
you know,
it's going on,
so I'm going to fucking talk about it because it's fun.
It's fun to shit on them.
Yeah.
But like,
I think this one,
people are so upset that they,
that their person didn't get in that now they're looking to blame.
So evidently the Monday morning podcast has the ability to sway a presidential
election
rent.
Well,
you know,
you do have a platform and you have to use it responsibly.
I'm going to start using this platform.
I think it's time everybody buys me a new car.
This will be good for America.
It's completely ridiculous.
People know who the fuck they gonna vote for.
Yeah.
And then it just needs to just need some time to,
I dunno,
I dunno if anyone's ever going to be fully okay with what just happened,
but,
well,
Trump supporters are totally,
yeah,
they're great.
Totally okay with it.
Good right now.
Yeah.
But,
oh well,
I'm glad she's fucking gone,
but I'm,
I'm not happy that he's here.
There was an,
there was a lose lose
situation.
Definitely depressing.
No matter how you slice it,
it's fucking depressing.
But life goes on.
It has to.
Yeah.
And you know something.
I don't think people should just fucking like it says it doesn't change who you
are going to be as a person.
Yeah.
I think if anything,
you just do what people are saying.
You stay here and you'd pay attention to what's going on and you support the
causes that mean a lot to you and just put all your effort behind that.
I feel like that's the way to like really make change.
Should you not move to Canada and no,
they don't want us.
I,
that was not funny thing too where they all acted like that they were going to
be so accepting.
Yeah.
Well yeah.
Okay.
That doesn't fucking want us like,
and I like how I feel like it's really arrogant to just be like,
oh,
I'm just going to move to Canada.
Canada is like,
okay,
do I have any say on this?
Like why do I become the place that you come to after your country made a
horror?
I know,
but the,
these are,
these are some of the great artistic minds on the planet would be gracing their
country with their songs and their standup comedy.
They should be happy.
They should welcome them with open arms.
Wow.
The ones I like,
the celebrities were like,
today my heart has tonight my heart cries but tomorrow I fight and they get the
little fucking muscle thing there.
It's like you probably go to your personal trainer first,
I would think.
Maybe have your personal chef make you guilty of that.
I put on Twitter that I cried,
but I felt hopeful because I did.
I've never cried after an election before and I did,
but I'm done crying,
I'm over crying and uh,
I'm ready to move forward and you know,
you can
just picture somebody's crying with their fucking downtown to ocean views.
What's going to happen to me?
Um,
yeah,
isn't it like mid term elections or something come up and like a year and a half
or something like that.
Then it was going to go the other way.
Now we'll see what happens in four years.
If he gets reelected or somebody else comes in.
I don't even know how,
I didn't even understand how the process works.
I'm going to keep throwing that out there cause I didn't know.
He said fucking clean support.
Can Bernie ran again and four years do you think?
No,
Bernie cannot win because he's not owned by the same seven corporations that you
need to be owned by.
I'm just throwing seven up.
He comes back and he runs in four years against Trump.
I would say the media will,
the left media,
we'll fucking take them out again.
They'll take,
but can he win?
Can you really win?
That's what they did.
They fucked him over.
They fucked him over and they left us with this polarizing person and then she
fucking lost and now people are all going,
what the fuck happened?
And they're blaming podcasts.
It's my fault.
Trump got in also.
It's also my flats.
Have you done this?
This fucking Trump supporter guy goes like you sitting there talking about the
cost of the wall.
How can you be so ignorant about the costs of the wall?
He goes to mobs of people that show yet there must have been.
It's so fucking dumb.
I actually think somebody,
uh,
democratic supporters sent it and he said every time he said,
who's going to pay for the wall,
the whole mob would yell Mexico.
Like,
how can you be so dumb that you didn't realize that?
Now that I'm saying that again,
I think that that,
I think someone was trolling me there.
I can't believe someone was that well,
but Trump's sad that he was like,
we're going to build a wall and Mexico's going to pay for it.
I know who would be dumb enough to think that you can make another country pay
for your shit.
We're going to build a wall to keep you out and you're going to pay for it.
I was saying that would be like if your neck,
if you didn't like your next door neighbor and you built a wall,
then you sent them a bill and it would be like,
ah,
make a paper airplane and just throw it back over.
I have no idea how he plans on enforcing that against,
so we'll see.
You know what I do love is that the first lady has fake tits.
I thought they weren't.
It was just to round.
How would we,
how would you possibly know that?
I don't know that and yeah,
I don't know anything.
I mean,
I've said that for fucking years.
That's true.
He has put it out there that he's got it.
He's got the president as a trophy wife.
It's fucking hilarious.
He's on his third one.
If you fucking act up,
don't even think you're going to be,
you're going to be sitting here picking up plates during my second term lady.
He has a wife like it doesn't even,
I don't know.
She doesn't even like register for me.
I mean,
yeah,
she's beautiful and all that,
but I don't really care.
I liked that she plagiarized Michelle Obama's speech,
which I think is really related to the millennials,
the way they cure rate,
you know,
Shit that they didn't do onto their Facebook pages and youtube pages and fucking
make all this money off of stuff that they didn't really do.
Oh you mean like sharing of memes and things,
sharing of standup specials and music and videos,
shit that they didn't do and they just take it.
Well I thought that was very millennial of our grandpa was that what the young
people do that is what they do.
Oh I fucking hate.
Or You just exonerated all of them from stealing all that shit.
Those specials costs me a bunch of fucking money and everybody just takes,
everyone should steal your special and are downloaded illegally.
Of course.
I don't believe that they should do that.
Yeah.
You have to understand that you have a platform on this podcast and all of those
people that were already doing it anyways.
There's now a bunch of others that are now going to do it cause you said it was
okay.
Hey,
you know what's weird is the wind screen is red.
Maybe I am a Trump supporter.
Oh,
maybe so maybe that was a subconscious decision on your part.
I liked the orange one,
but cleo ate it.
It reminded me of fucking ABC's wide world of sports with Jim Mckay,
who I knew you were an elephant.
You seem like a jackass to me.
Nothing.
Oh,
I didn't get it.
I didn't get all that.
Those are the animals,
right?
Jesus Democrats are really donkeys.
Why would they pick that?
I don't know it a reason behind it.
We just haven't.
Wicca,
PD googled it,
whatever.
Well,
I'm sure someone will tell me why.
Preempting it.
Hey,
you fucking moron.
I'm all right.
That's the podcast.
Uh,
I'm sorry for Donald Trump.
next time I will try to,
uh,
I haven't made up my mind who I want to be president yet.
Uh,
the next time I think I'm already over Trump and a I will,
I'll figure it out.
Yeah,
I hope so.
So this doesn't happen again.
You fucking election rigor.
You can regular you all right?
That's it.
I gotta I gotta fucking upload this shit and I got to go edit.
My goddamn specialist is going to be the worst fucking thing ever.
All right.
Go for it.
He sells,
we'll talk to you on Thursday.